lock-and-key is here to enchant us with
a spooky house filled with magical keys
and a mysterious malevolent demon yippie
chi may be lovers I'm John and in this
video I'm diving deep into the secrets
of key house to explain everything you
might have missed in the first season of
lock and key
I'll also be revealing the truth about
what's really behind the black door the
final twist and what to expect in season
two there will of course be spoilers so
take care to properly understand the
origin and the magical keys and where
the demon Dodge comes from we need to
take a closer look at the black door
deep inside matheson sea caves what we
know from the series so far is that many
years ago on the night of Randall Locke
and his friends graduation they went to
the caves to investigate a mysterious
door they discovered weeks earlier after
Randall opened the door
glowing bullets shot through from the
other side and one hit Lucas although he
seemed fine initially later that night
Lucas became enraged and demanded the
others hand over the major key that
opens the black door
Lucas was so angry that he killed two of
his friends until Randall killed him
with a hammer in the comic book series
that the TV shows based on the black
door is a gateway to another dimension
inhabited by demons that can possess
humans who come into contact with them
similar to the whispering he's in key
house the black door calls and whispers
to those who enter the cave mesmerizing
them
which explains why Rendell was so
obsessed with opening the door and why
Kinsey refuses to leave the door when
she first discovers it whenever the
portal is open demons are able to travel
across the threshold via glowing bullets
as they cross through the door the
demons are vulnerable and quickly
require a human host to survive
otherwise they die in turn into
whispering iron which is especially
interesting because whispering iron is
also the special metal that key houses
magical keys are made from many years
after Lucas's death his girlfriend Allie
missed him so much that she used the
echo key to bring an echo of him back by
entering the well house with the key and
calling his name what Allie didn't
realize at a time was that this
resurrected the demon who'd taken over
her boyfriend demon Lucas however was
trapped for the time being inside the
well house because the rules of the key
prevents an echo from leaving in fact in
the comics if the echo leaves through
the well house door it will fade away
and cease to exist
however the any work he offers an echo a
way of bypassing this rule and escaping
by the way the magical properties of the
well house may also be connected to the
portal and the sea caves in the comics
the black door is located right beneath
the well house and in the TV show each
time anyone goes to the black door they
have to travel deep into the cave system
yeah we should hurry that is not what
you said before yeah took a lot longer
to get down here than I thought Duncan
also tells the family that the well has
been contaminated with salt water
meaning that when the sea floods the
tunnels in the caves the water must
reach all the way to the well house
while he's stuck in the well House demon
Lucas hatches a plan to find where
Randall is keeping me anywhere key and
uses the identity key to change his
appearance to a female form called dodge
which was Ellie's nickname for Lucas
dodge there magically appears and
communicates to some lesser one of
Randall students fire a picture of key
house in Randall's office this moment
reminded me of Pennywise coming to life
and talking to the losers in a book of
old photos in it in lock and key Sam's
attempts to get the key from Randall
fail and he ends up killing him in the
process however when the surviving
locked family moves into key house dodge
is able to restart her scheme when Bodie
wanders into the well house Dodge
befriends him then
Simmonds are handing over the anyw'ere
key which she promptly uses to escape
once free dodge begins her mission to
collect as many keys as possible in
particular she's after the Omega key so
she can open the black door and although
dodges motivation hasn't been stated
explicitly in the TV show it's likely
going to be similar to the comics where
dodge wants to bring over fellow demons
to conquer our world after Bodhi refuses
to hand over any more to her the very
next scene introduces us to Gabe who's
later revealed to be another of dodges
alter egos that she transforms into
using the identity came as soon as dodge
realizes Bodhi will no longer cooperate
she switches to an even sneakier
strategy of infiltrating the lock family
by making friends with Kinzie the first
scene with Gabe has several clues that
already hint he may not really be who he
appears to be first of all he was a
lobster suit as he's playing the part of
a legendary local monster that's half
lobster half human
of course Gabe is pretty monstrous
himself as in reality he's basically
wearing a human suit as he's a demon
playing the part of a human Scott also
mentions that Gabe is new to Matheson
and the Invisible Man poster on the wall
is another hint there's a villain hiding
in plain sight Gabe's suspect nature is
also foreshadowed when he encourages
Kinzie to go down to the sea caves when
the rest of the Savini squad are
reluctant to do so and after she finds
the black door for the first time he
begins to burrow into Kinzie's
affections becoming a romantic rival to
Scott Gabe sneaking around appears to
pay off big time because when Kinzie
suggests dating both Scott and Gabe
Scott turns her down leaving Gabe in a
prime trusted position as Kinsey's
boyfriend meaning he'll be able to keep
track of everything the Locke family do
in season 2 after dodge escapes from the
well house she also uses the identity
key to transform back into Lucas and
stay at Ali's house when Ellie
eventually turns on him Lucas decides to
get rid of her to do that he uses the
identity key first on himself to
transform into Dodge and next on Ellie
to turn her into a dodge look-alike the
real dodge then takes the unconscious
fake dodge to hkey house and during the
attack with the crown of Shadows she
plants fake dodges body there so the
think they've caught the real dodge
Tyler Kinsey and their friends then
throw fake dodge through the black door
into the alternate dimension without
ever realizing the person they've tossed
behind the door is actually Ellie it's
unclear whether a human being can
survive on the other side of the black
door but it feels like there's a
possible parallel between the upside
down in stranger things and the
alternate dimension in lock and key
which in the comics is known by the
Lovecraftian name the plains of Lang ok
spoilers for stranger things now in that
show some characters have been able to
survive their time in the upside down
Nancy wheeler for example crossed over
for just a short moment and was
unaffected however will Byers was
trapped there for a much longer period
of time and survived though he suffered
from PTSD and became affected by the
shadow monster in the lock and key
comics the demon dodge describes its
world as extremely unforgiving and it
seems unlikely that a human could
survive in such a place however the TV
show has already made numerous changes
to the source material so we'll have to
wait and see the season 2 will also be
getting a new second villain in the form
of mean girl eden who was infected by a
demon when one of the glowing bullets
hit her as it came through the black
door has also happened years previously
with Ellie's boyfriend Lucas Eden
suffered no immediately obvious ill
effects and none of the other characters
noticed what happened at the time so
thus far the event has gone unnoticed
however in the very final scene of
season one we see Eden working her way
through an enormous spread just like
dodge did after she emerged from the
well house the one character who is
aware what Eden's hiding is dodge who we
see meet up with her in the form of Gabe
speaking of Eden and Gabe is intriguing
that both their names have biblical
connections Eden being the paradise Adam
and Eve were expelled from after being
corrupted by the serpent and Gabe being
a short form of Gabriel an angel he was
usually a divine messenger who brought
good news although Eden in Gabe's
demonic natures may seem to be at odds
with their heavenly names it's actually
strangely fitting as the idea of their
characters is that they're not what they
appear to be
the surface as they're really demons
hiding out as humans the secondary
villain from season one that Eden will
be replacing is Sam lesser whose
physical body died when the ghost key
separated his spirit from his body and
the door was then closed in the comic
Sam's ghost continues to play a part in
the story and expect he will return next
season in his spirit form and they work
against dodge now that she's revealed
she never thought he was special at all
with his mother alley missing Rufus has
been taken in by his uncle and Nebraska
but we do see Bodhi writing to him at
the end and promising to use the
anywhere key to come and find him in the
comics Rufus plays a crucial part and
eventually defeating dodge and I think
his close friendship with Bodhi means
we'll hopefully see him return so what
did you think of the first season of
lock and key and do you have any
theories for season two comment with
your thoughts below and if you enjoyed
this be sure to subscribe for all my new
videos including Netflix as Sabrina you
Lucifer and stranger things tapleft to
check out my full Netflix playlists or
tap right for another video you're sure
to like thanks for watching and see you
next time you big a movie lovers